[Music]
talk to others
about this and how becoming plant-based
when you make that switch
there's a level of compassion and
empathy that just happens
and i don't understand it completely but
it definitely happened for me
and the way
i i sleep easier at night and i have
this this
this overwhelming sense of that it's the
right move
just based on the fact that i i'm not
creating suffering for any other beings
and
that aspect of it has definitely come to
the forefront for me
and as i was running across the country
there were a lot of livestock that i
came in contact with i saw way more cows
than people
and understood and much i grew up my
grandfather had cattle
when i was young you know you're not
really thinking too deep about much
but um one thing that i definitely
the thing i gained along the way was
just how aware these these animals were
and how much they were they were curious
beings they
cars go by all day they know what a car
is they don't know what a guy running is
they want to come see what it is and
they're playful they'll come to the
fence when you're running come to the
fence and run with you
there was a day where it was
it was one of the few days it snowed i
woke up and there was snow all over the
ground
and i started my my daily miles and
there had been a calf
who had been separated from its mother
had somehow gotten out of the fence
so it was on the roadside with me very
desolate road in the middle of oklahoma
i believe
and i had for the better part of an hour
had to hear this calf cry for its mother
and its mother get separated from the
pack and
keep looking between do i go with the
pack how do i want to stay with my child
and it was gut wrenching it was no
different than seeing that in a human
and eventually luckily the calf found a
spot to get back through and it made its
way to his mother and they trotted off
but
that part matters that part of the
advocacy matters more to me now than
ever
um and those two right there and i mean
just overall
health and well-being you know we live
in a in a
society with a lot of problems and a lot
of good things but
you look at a lot of the problems in
front of us and that was when i got into
this i felt there was this like
this naive epiphany that
a plant-based lifestyle was like a
silver bullet it could take care of so
many of the problems in front of us it
could take
we we have all these talks and all of
this
debate about health care and how to how
to approach health care in america what
if people just weren't sick
you know uh the environmental crisis
it's huge it's looming and
animals production animal production
equates for
you know it said over 50 of the
degradation of
our environment silver bullet
right just eat plants and so that that
it
means it does mean a lot to me and it
has evolved a lot over time
and it's just there's three pillars to
it to me there's environmentalism
ethical and health and those three still
stand true it's like what matters and
why it is such an important
topic one important enough to run across
the country for
yeah it checks all of those boxes if we
avoid
animal products in our diet
we can avoid chronic lifestyle illnesses
we can sidestep the environmental
wreckage
that this industry provokes and produces
and we get to spare the lives of these
sentient beings and we need not
raise so many of them only to lead them
to
you know a most unpleasant demise
exactly
um so it seems like really elementary to
me
but i think the role of the athlete
what's so important about the athlete is
people might intellectually be able to
kind of understand that but then they
still think yeah but i'm going to be
deficient or i'm not going to feel good
or i'm not going to be able to
do what i want to do in my life so you
can go
and get in front of a microphone and say
the things that you just said
but ultimately the power in your message
is the fact that you got across the
country in 75 days on two feet
which is undeniable and
can't be debated yeah right
and that there so that was one of the
reasons
i got into this too was as we were
making all these changes in our life and
we were talking about plant-based and we
had gone vegetarian
uh i was expressing this to
friends and family and they knew that i
liked to run a lot and there was that
thing of well you can't do this robbie
like you you really you're going to need
you need that meat for strength so you
can run
and it was just one of those things of
like well
what's a way to prove that you know and
that that was definitely circling around
in this time
yeah and going into this i wasn't really
aware of plant-based advocacy
you know i didn't understand that there
were so many others out there
that were working towards this and some
you know
that was an interesting thing to realize
that there was a whole fraternity of
others that were involved
which has really been awesome to
understand and see and i do yeah i think
athletes we we
do poison we stand poison a very
interesting position
because it's if it's good for us why is
it good not good for everyone else
you know yeah again if we can perform at
this well then everybody in their normal
lives and weekend warriors
it's good for them too right the human
mind though is pretty good at
at denial and dissonance so it's you
know they'll look at
what what what happens unfortunately is
the more extreme and audacious the
athletic feat
like in the case of yourself running
across the country
it then becomes unrelatable and then you
just become
an outlier who's easily dismissed as
like a freak
like yeah he could do it but like he's
he's like you know he's not like me
yeah so then the challenge becomes you
have to bring it back and make it
relatable again and that's why i think
it's important
for you to talk about the fact that you
haven't been a runner your whole life
that's why i wanted to hear like that
part of the story too because i think
people can see themselves in that that
you're not some crazy super
human superman guy i mean you clearly
have talent and ability and all of that
and a work ethic
um but uh it's not like oh you were
you're an nc2a track you know track and
field superstar
coming into this no not at all you know
i've never ran a boston qualifying
marathon
uh yeah did you play sports when you
were a kid yeah i played team sports
growing up
you know i um played football in high
school i was
i was a good football player i wasn't
great i didn't i didn't play in college
or anything
and then after that i was i was not an
athlete for a while i rode bikes
uh fixed gear bikes around austin just
became like a young little thug
and spent a lot of time in the bars and
yeah was much more
in favor of that lifestyle and wasn't
taking care of myself or my body and
you know when i moved to alaska i think
i was up to about
230 pounds wow you know i'm at 170 now
and
i've fluctuated a lot no i've not always
been in touch with my body on like an
athletic level
and only in the last two years have i to
a
high performing level um
it's a great place to be now though and
i do know that you know i've just the
tip of the iceberg like i want to
continue to push and i have like a sense
of
i feel legit now you feel dude you're
legit
we can just end that part of that right
there what what else did you learn about
yourself like this is a journey of
self-discovery it's
mental and emotional and spiritual i
would argue even more than it was a
physical feed it's like
you had to confront yourself in profound
ways like what did you
learn um
on the surface level uh devices
uh our phones are distracting us from a
lot of things that really matter
being forced to not be around my phone
for so long
was so amazing and allowed me to ponder
life
and also be open to people when i did
come in contact with them
that was a really big thing you know i
think we put up a lot of walls and we
have a lot of labels
for different types of people and
different people in regions of the
country and stuff and
we get all of that those these
assumptions about each other based on
updates on our phone and having to put
that down and interact with others i
found that people were extremely
beautiful and awe-inspiring and
just interesting just the the random
like
guy in overalls in missouri
just blow your mind with the stuff that
they have to say
um that was a big thing
um yeah i mean just to extrapolate on
that a little bit sorry to interrupt
um if you're on twitter it's very easy
to fall into a state of despair thinking
that we're
at each other's throats and that we live
in you know in a country that's very
much divided
ideologically politically um and there's
a lot of
like vitriol and and downright hatred
out there and
there is um but there's something about
the tactile experience of boots on the
ground
at that slow of a pace that gives you a
very different lens like i have a friend
who every year
takes a train he's not you know he's not
an ultra distance runner but he takes a
train cross country every year and he
gets off at every stop and spends time
and
connects with people in a real way and
and you know he will say
and i'm sure you will echo this you know
what i s what
my my real life experience of going to
all these places
is very different than what you would
imagine based upon the narrative that's
being propagated by
social media and um and even you know
news and newspapers and the like yeah i
couldn't agree more
we're giving up a lot of our power and a
lot of
our ability to connect to
these devices and these few powers that
be that
run them or it's not even that i don't
think that there's some like body
orchestrating it from behind i think
it's just what's happened
it's just the way we're receiving
information it's through a filter that's
not reality
and there's just a lot more beauty out
there and we have a lot more in common
than we have
we have these key issues that are stupid
and well they're not some they're not
stupid but there's
there's a lot more to a human and to
individuals than what were
what we're getting through these updates
and through what we see on social media
um that one was very big that was
profound for me
i had definitely put a lot of those
walls up for myself
um and then the other one and also
sorry i'm doing it again but um going
back to
truly the original catalyst for this
whole thing was an ideological
difference with your aunt
yeah yeah exactly and
you know that was a struggle the
struggle i went through and a lot of
people went through was
this just immense love for someone or
multiple people in your life that you
see something so
so polarly opposite from and it helps to
come back and heal those things or have
a better understanding of that
those small differences don't equate to
enough to feel
separate from those that you love that
might see things differently or even a
random person on the street
how are you and your aunt now oh we're
great oh you are oh that's cool
we have always been she was someone that
i mean i love her to no end and
you know she's been there for me and is
still there for me at times and right
now
in such a profound way and that's what
made it so that's what makes it so
painful when we get into these like
political debates like
there's just it's such a minute part of
who we are as individuals as
as those things so yeah that was there
was a lot of self-discovery in that for
[Music]
sure